Beyonce making her story at the Grammys
but loses out on album of the Year again
The Beehive and Harry's are fighting
y'all welcome everybody to Entertainment
Tonight but here is something that we
can all agree on the 14 minutes of
perfection by some of the biggest MC's
in hip-hop history that will go down as
one of the greatest Grammy performances
of all time
[Applause]
how was it I mean it was incredible man
to really give the Grammy audience of
authentic Taste of hip-hop
Unity is all I keep thinking over and
over again I know I'm gonna hear it
you're gonna lose your mind when that
segment comes Queen Latifah LL Cool J
and iced tea were among the 33 artists
to take part in this Vision curated by
The Roots star questler
calls me up and he says all right you
got to come to LA this weekend he said
you don't want to be sitting at home
watching the show and I got my black ass
on the plane Questlove told us a behind
the scenes secret Will Smith was on
board to join DJ Jazzy Jeffy Jeff
he was literally
99.44 and but they started shooting bad
boys for this week so he couldn't make
rehearsals I had to cut so many people
off well clearly the audience was all in
from Adele and lizzo to Jay-Z who nearly
lost his mind during Busta Rhymes super
fast flow
getting the opportunity to shine
In This Moment it's really tear-jerking
Nelly meanwhile went old school with the
Band-Aid on his face while taking his
spot on stage I'm honored I get the
chance to be included
Missy Elliott and salt and pepper also
helped represent the female emcee
[Applause]
50 years We're not gonna be here for the
next 50. so to celebrate it here at the
Grammys is awesome but can we all bow
down to the queen breaking the record
for the most scrummy wins of all time
and I'm trying to just
receive this night after arriving one
hour late and missing her best r b song
award which was presented by newly
crowned egot winner Viola Davis Beyonce
got a standing ovation for her 30-second
Grammy I'd like to thank my beautiful
husband
my beautiful three children but the
Beehive is buzzing today outraged that
Beyonce still hasn't won album of the
year but that didn't break her soul last
night inside Beyonce hug Taylor posed
with lizzo and even Adele who beat out
her Idol for best pop performance to how
great a night was it oh it was fantastic
it was fantastic you know I love my life
would be able to say hello
Adele was one of the most popular Stars
at the Grammys but we couldn't take our
eyes off that diamond ring on that
finger so did her man Rich Paul propose
reps didn't respond but last time Adele
wore a rock on that finger she said I'm
not engaged I just love high-end jewelry
well how about the singer's full circle
moment with this rock get up here best
friend Adele the two just met only two
and a half hours earlier the rock meet
Adele first time ever
How's Mama thank you she's doing really
good I appreciate that just five days
ago Duane's mom had to got into a near
fatal car crash it was a scary moment
that was 3 A.M when I get that phone
call and you know we know when that
phone rings at 3am and it's a family
member
it's not good she put the paramedics on
and I said hello this is Dwayne Johnson
I'm a paramedic said oh no I know she's
been telling us she's a Rock's mom
because it's about damn time the Grammy
goes to lizzo for about 10 pounds yeah
the Grammys flash chugging selfie
snapping greatest fan girl ever won
record of the year with an epic shout
out to the competition Beyonce
you changed my life and someone else
[Applause]
[Music]
that'd be her boyfriend of nearly two
years comedian Mike Wright lizzo
captioned their pre-grammy PDA hard
launch last night lizzo got a smooch
from Harry Styles leaping to her feet
when he beat out her Beyonce and Adele
for album of the year and yeah that's
Adele not standing for the surprise win
[Music]
Harry how is it to perform at the
Grammys how much money it was matches
Harry took home two Grammys we saw Adele
jokingly pretend to leave in the middle
of his speech right after 78 year old
superfan grandma Arena did the honors
but playing the role of Harry's
supportive ex Taylor Swift
[Music]
check it out the standing o during both
of Harry's wins the stop at his table
for a chat the dancing during his
performance a source tells E.T the two
are friendly and Taylor has nothing but
respect for Harry
Tay was spotted partying with another
winner Bad Bunny who opened the show and
that ring on his finger has fans
wondering did he get secretly married to
his longtime girlfriend Gabby the 28
year old shut down similar rumors to E.T
in 2020. no I'm not that married are you
engaged
maybe he can be there but leave it to
binnifer to have us re-watching the show
trying to lip read this I think JLo says
don't do that and rewinding for every
moment turned mean sad Ben bringing Zoom
call energy to the Grammys when the wife
brings you to a work event blink if
you're okay and our fave joking Ben
would rather be at Duncan the donut
chain entered the chat to say we will be
there for him in the morning
cardi how was it presenting I was so
nervous backstage et's cameras caught
this blow up from presenter cardi B
so what went down it appears tensions
boiled over between the remaining
members of Migos Cardi's has been offset
and his cousin cuevo I heard you back
here settling some stuff the only thing
I said was my outfit honey
performing for takeoffs in memoriam
tribute today offset denied the fight on
Twitter
how important was it to be here tonight
to perform
very important long little takeoff Donna
how good is it to be here tonight pretty
good
he caught Madonna backstage two her look
has definitely evolved in the 24 years
since her Grammy debut are you
and Kim Petras who set the Grammys on
fire with their performance of Unholy
and also made history I'm the first
transgender woman to win this award
ET spoke with Kim at the Universal Music
group's after party I was happy dancing
on tables and gate clubs you know I make
gay club music they got a Grammy and
from maren Morris and Ryan Hurd to Paris
Hilton with Carter Reed Grammys was date
night it's about to get hot in here
Miranda Lambert was matching in silver
and black with Brittany McLaughlin
looking way more dressed up than the
couple's recent anniversary snap I told
him that he was given this and he needs
to share with the world Happy four years
to you guys how's it been it's been
awesome it's been great it's been easy
inside the lovebirds posed with fellow
country star Luke Combs and his wife
Nicole and he took the Grammy stage for
the very first time
[Music]
how is fatherhood oh man real exciting
we were just FaceTiming with him before
the carpet he was like recognizing his
mom and me what is this made of Angel
skin Megan Fox and Machine Gun Kelly
coordinated their silver looks MGK's
publicist carried the hot pink wrist
brace Megan needed after suffering a
concussion and broken wrist
your lady looks real good she's the most
the most beautiful she's Godly yeah
absolutely MGK didn't win big but Brandy
Carlisle did taking home three trophies
and rocking the stage after her wife
Catherine and two daughters introduced
her performance
[Applause]
I think it was Porsha that posted it of
Ellen's birthday you were singing at
their vow renewal yes Porsha was like
apropos of nothing will you burst into
the verse the first verse of the first
time ever I saw your face and I was like
absolutely now I also saw Harry and
Megan in the crowd they just really felt
like very normal decent good humored
people we've had a great chat as for
Kelsey ballerini her new boo outer
Banks's Chase Stokes was not by her side
but her mom was and they snuck out of
the show early hitting up Craig's for
dinner mid-show my mom is my date how
hot is she I love that how hot is she
[Applause]
[Music]
well everyone was on their feet JLo The
Rock Jay-Z went 25-time Grammy winner
Stevie Wonder and Chris Stapleton
brought down the house in a thrilling
tribute to Motown Legends Smokey
Robinson and Barry Gordy it was
fantastic you know a good number of
Stevie if you can't feel that you're
dead man
Stevie met Smokey when he was only 10.
yes because I was saying I said yeah
I don't know about all that
[Music]
[Applause]
way
so how was it on this day oh boy we had
a ball we had a young group man golly
they are incredible well and their dad
of course one of the singers for boys
and men why no more
[Music]
right now
like a couple days ago they called us
and they were like yo we want you to
perform on the Grammys we were like
giving you all for 100 of the time 100
yeah it's insane
[Music]